الرياضيات ايش فيها رياضيات مشاهدينا قد
تكون معقده وممله
نتائج دراسه جديده اجرتها وكاله ابحاث
السوق وان بول في بريطانيا على مجموعه من
الطلاب وجدت ان ثلث البالغين يصابون
بالقلق من ماده الرياضيات بحسب نتائج يخاف
واحد من كل خمسه طلاب من الرياضيات بدرجه
تفوق الاصابه بالامراض حتى اعترف اخرون
انهم لم يركزوا في دروس الرياضيات لانها
لا تساعد في الحياه
العمليه واخيرا
35% من المشاركين قالوا انهم سيتجنبون
تولي اي وظيفه لها علاقه بالحسابات
على فكره انت ذكرت قبل شوي بتقول انه يعني
كثير من المعلومات الحسابيه او الرياضيه
اللي تعلمناها ما بنستفيد منها
عمرك كنت تفكر بهذا الحكي وانت كنت
بالمدرسه بتدرس رياضيات انا ماني فاهم
الرياضيات على كل حال لانه اطفالنا بهلا
بهاي المرحلهم كثير بيسالوني هذا السؤال
انه بنتي بتسالني طب انا ليه عم بتعلم انا
مش راح استعمله على كل حال مشاهدينا عالم
الرياضيات الانجليزي جيمز
يقول ان الرياضيات هي موسيقى العقل
شو رايك طبيعي عالم رياضيه
اكيد يمدح ما راح يمدح بلاي ستيشن مثلا بي
اس 5 وغيره مثلا كما لكن تدرين انه عدد من
الدراسات تصنف القلق او او فوبيا
الرياضيات هي ظاهره عالميه طبعا
تكون وباء معقول يصيرون
طيب انا يعني ممكن اتفهم في ناس ما بيحبوا
الرياضيات بس ليش راح يخافوا من الرياضيات
ويصيبهم هلا الهلع هذا الى هذا الحد في
ناس تعتقد بانه يعني بيرجع الى الخوف
والاحراج امام الاخرين يعني واحد يسالك
اوكيه 8 في 76 بس 9 في 4 9 في 4 ما ادري
والله انا نسيت بصراحه يعني هذا الاحراج
امام الاخرين هذه
ماده قد يعتبر هالبعض مرتبطه بالذكاء
الخارق بالتالي الفشل في حل المسائل يضعك
في موقف محرج او انه هذا شخص قليل الفهم
او غبي يعني بالتجارب غير صحيحه
على كل حال هو في نوع من انواع الارتباط
اعاده المباني على ما يبدو المسائل
الرياضيه وقدرتنا على حلها وما بين الاي
كي وعلى هيك الربط ما بين الذكاء
والرياضيات بس في انواع كثير من الذكاء في
ذكاء في المواد الادبيه ذكاء ادبي ذكاء
عاطفي هذا اللي ما فهم يعني ما فهمت الاسر
في الاونه الاخيره من انه ابنك قد يتميز
في ماده معينه لكنه ليس بالضروره ان يكون
او طفل ممتاز في كل المواد فبالتالي لا
تظلمه بانه تركز انه ياتي بالعام بالعلامه
الكامله ليس صحيحا وكل كل طفل او كل شخص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات